wanna be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you two
you've got michael jordan level talent
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and get some
insane motivation from bishop td jakes
enjoy
i am afraid that too many times
we have spent so much focus on teaching
you to be good seed
that we haven't taught you the power of
good soil
and so when we come to soil issues
the seed ignores the soil
we flick the channel that has nothing to
do with me
we closed our eyes because we have been
taught to be
good seed but we have not been taught to
pay attention
to soil and yet the bible is clear jesus
says
the sword went forth sowing seed
and some fell by the wayside some fell
amongst rocks some fell among storage
the whole text is about environment
[Applause]
look at you and look at your
environment
have you been positioned to flourish
positioning has a lot to do with
flourishing
to be in an environment in a family that
supports you my sister and i were
talking the other day
i was telling her what an amazing person
she is that all of our lives together
and and all the things that god did in
my life not once
in all of the years that i've known her
and she was there when mama had me
have i ever known her to be jealous of
me
not once not ever she has always been my
cheerleader my greatest fan
and she said how could i be jealous of
you you're my brother i said a lot of
people
have siblings that hate them that are
jealous of them that hope they choke
and some of my development has to be
that god
planted me in an environment of people
that supported me my brother my sister
my mother my father they all
supported me you can have good seed
but if you've been in bad soil
people who hated you environments that
denied you
education that underserved you
communities that limited you
mentalities that poisoned you
oh do you hear what i'm saying if if
your
soil wasn't right it doesn't mean that
you're not right
but if your soil wasn't right it's gonna
affect how you root and how you grow
and you might grow a little bit the
bible says you can grow for a while
but then the gorge will choke you out or
the rocks
will not have enough soil for your roots
to grow
are you blaming god for something you
ought to be blaming the soil for
you cannot take a peach seed
and plant it in a teaspoon of dirt
and expect it to grow though the
teaspoon of the dirt is the same size as
the peach seed
it will not grow the seed will only grow
when it is planted in something bigger
than itself
and i want to know where are you playing
it this morning
are you planted in something bigger than
you
or have you always been planted in
teacups
surrounded by little dirt little
resources
small-minded people narrow limited
places
that never let you stretch to reach your
capacity
sometimes you got to go where the corn
is
do you have the courage to act
outwardly on what you see inwardly
[Applause]
or will you die a dreamer will you die
on the verge and on the edge and on in
the land of cutter
water and shoulda
[Applause]
this wrong hand rules the roost
do you have the courage i'm gonna drop
something on you
it takes courage to be successful
[Applause]
it is far easier not to be successful
[Applause]
misery will always have company
success breeds contempt
[Music]
if you don't want to make waves be
mediocre
be normal and fit in and if you're more
concerned about people than you
are god then neutralize everything he
put in you
just fit in with everybody else dress
like them
walk like them act like them eat like
them go where they go
think like they think do what they do
and once you've neutralized your
uniqueness
you don't need courage it takes courage
to be different
it takes courage to go where you've
never gone before
for some of you it took courage to come
to this conference
it takes courage to get you outside of
the bar it takes courage to be
successful
it takes courage to win people don't
talk about people that don't win
if you win they're going to talk about
you do you have the courage
to stand there though the storms keep
raising
and the people get to talking and you
stand there and say i've come too far
to turn around that's your girlfriend
and say
do you have the carrots
i'm gonna i'm gonna say something to you
it takes courage to be exceptional
it takes courage to be wise it takes
courage to be rich
it takes courage to be educated it takes
courage to be knowledgeable
because the moment you do it you don't
talk like you oh you didn't god forgot
where you came from
look at you it takes courage
and i'm just wondering in this weak
watered-down
mediocre society that we live in today
in this reality tv world we live in
today
i'm wondering if there's anybody left
that's got the courage
to say after all i've been through and
all my ancestors have been through
and all my parents have been through i
didn't come through all of that
just to fit in with normalcy i have the
courage
to go after my dream my challenge
in our generation is that gradually
through entertainment through
television through media through every
way possible we are living in a
generation of the dumbing
down of ideas because
we have traded effectiveness
for busyness statistics say
yeah somebody ought to clap on that
we are busier than any other generation
we have seen
in the last three to four hundred years
we are so busy we're
we are busier than a wall we've been a
one-armed wallpaper hangar we're just
busy
you'll get it later don't worry about it
it'll hit you in a minute we are just as
busy as we can be and we think because
we're busy
we're effective but i want you to
challenge your schedule for a minute
and ask yourself are you are you really
being effective
or is your life cluttered with all kinds
of stuff
that demands you and drains you and
taxes you
and stops you from being your highest
and best self
and are you substituting busyness and
all the chaos that goes along with
business
from being effective let me tell you a
bunch of scientists got together they
begin to do some research
and they begin to determine that 80
percent of the things
we do are busy things that we do in an
area that is not effective that the
average person only spends
20 percent of their time doing the thing
that they are really
gifted at created at passionate about
excited to do and the rest of it is all
the dismal dumb stuff that we all have
to do in order to survive
just crazy stuff that we're doing wonder
what would happen
if we would go from doing 80 of things
that are busy but not effective
and 20 of the things that are really
effective if we would
switch those numbers around and only
give 20
of our time to the things that we have
to do and 80
of our time to the thing that we were
created to do
[Music]
wonder what would happen to your life
now think about it a minute i
there's a lot of things you could take
from me and i could make it you could
take my suit
i got another one you could take my car
i could get another one
you could take my house i could get
another house
but when you take my time
you have taken something from me that is
totally
irreplaceable we take all kind of
classes for money management
we know how to manage our money we know
how to repair our houses
we're working on our hair and our bodies
and all of this kind of stuff
we do everything except the most
important thing is to value
our time it takes time
to be creative you were meant to be
creative you were created in the
likeness and the image of a creator
and in that likeness and in that image
you have
creativity if you had time
you would be creative but in the absence
of time
and with busyness and clutter and people
the following baby
y'all got music playing on your phone
all kinds of stuff and no matter what
kind of song you put on after a while
you hate to hear it
because every time you hear that sound
you know it somebody else
wants something else from you that's
taking you away
from what you are gifted and creative to
do also if you want to have unstoppable
confidence self-love and learn from
other black
leaders check out my 254 series they're
free
the links to join are in the description
below to be anxious is to have
anxiety about something that hadn't even
happened yet
so many times you've thrown big ideas
as small people you are allowing
weaknesses mistakes
traumas who didn't love you who wasn't
there for you who didn't stand by you
to define you when a person picks this
book up
what are you wanting them to get from
this
i want them to understand that you are
the architect
of tomorrow i based it on the wright
brothers who had the audacity
to believe that they could build
something that would take them from the
ground to the air
and so they built this without a degree
without having financiers oh you don't
need an education to make it
oh yeah
they didn't let they didn't let any of
the things that normally stop us i don't
have the money i don't have the capital
i don't have the manufacturing in fact
they built the first plane in a bicycle
shop
the other thing that i think is
important to mention the gravitational
pull that the wright brothers had to
break through
is a law that whatever goes up must come
down isaac newton was absolutely right
but they found a higher law by pushing
the limits on the lower law
they found the law of aerodynamics most
entrepreneurs when you start building
something or you're trying to build a
marriage or you're trying to build a
child
there is a gravitational pull that says
you don't belong up here
come down to where you belong wow but if
you keep pushing against
what's pulling you back you'll break
into another law
yeah god wants you to be
excited about your destiny so that you
can endure the process
that brings you into promise
[Applause]
because there is a process before
promise
and if you don't have at least a vision
of the promise
the process will discourage you but
every time discouragement is trying to
get you to give up the process
remember the vision you have with the
promise and keep on walking around the
wall
keep on walking around i'm tired lord
but i'm gonna walk around this wall
i'm frustrated lord but i'm gonna walk
around this wall i'm lonely lord but i'm
gonna walk around this wall
ministry's not growing but i'm gonna
walk around this wall thought i'd be
married by now but i'm gonna walk around
this wall
lost the first house applying for the
second house i'm gonna walk around this
wall
credit's all jack lord but i can walk
around this wall
i'm trusting you when i can't trace you
i'm gonna walk around this wall
and lord i am crazy enough to stand in
front of a solid wall
and shout as if it had already come
down let's try that one time
let's shout as if the walls had already
come
[Applause]
down
people think i often well that's for
those people over there
or when i get when i get myself together
when i get myself together i'm going to
live on purpose
but you say it is possible wherever you
are right now
facebook anywhere in the world watching
us
that even if you're in the middle of a
disaster
right you can use that disaster
for direction absolutely because it is
through the disaster it is through the
adversity
that our strength is developed if
everything went the way you wanted it to
go you wouldn't have anything to
exercise by it's it's a gymnasium of
life where you get the workout the
resistance and you find out things about
yourself
that you didn't know i'm stronger than i
thought i was i'm tougher than what i
thought i was i'm more resilient than i
thought i was and that
self-respect stops you from being at the
mercy of
other people to validate you to make you
feel good about who you are
what is something you'd suggest to add
to our daily routine
to empower ourselves quiet
quiet we're too busy we are so busy that
we don't notice that we're not
productive
busy does not mean that you you are
producing if we are just spinning our
wheels
and and the great thinking and progress
that we've made in this country
steam engines telephones uh automobiles
uh all types of things uh spacecrafts
were done by people who had moments to
think we're moving so fast at
breakneck speed and if we get a free
moment
we're we're on twitter and facebook and
everything
it's the death of creativity and i would
challenge people
to to go back to meditation and and if
your spiritual go back to prayer if
you're not
just go back to just laying still for a
moment to clear your head
to hit the reset button because we are
starting every day
with the burdens from yesterday
assaulting us
in today let's put a comma between all
of this i read somewhere as an actor i
think said it that
once a week he doesn't talk
doesn't talk all day yeah just peace
yeah yeah just be
shut it all down and you'd be surprised
what you can hear
when you shut up it is not what you
think about
god that is holding you it is what you
think about you
that is holding oh they didn't let me
try it on them it is not what you think
about god
that is holding you you got great
thoughts about god
it is what you think about you
that keeps bringing you back down to
playing the same role
in the same movie over and over again
you will not accept god's script
god has a script for you to go by you
will not accept
god's script because you are allowing
weaknesses mistakes traumas who didn't
love you who wasn't there for you who
didn't stand by you
to define you and you are letting the
enemy
script you for the life jesus
died to give you have you franchised
what works in your life
that's what the second step is so many
people become fruitful and they say this
is working and i've done this and i've
accomplished this
but i'm not fulfilled at it anymore and
i'm frustrated i wonder why
i'm i feel the way i do the reason you
do because you haven't taken the second
step
once it works in a microcosm in a
controlled environment
in this city or that neighborhood or
this place
you want to then multiply that which is
fruitful
you want to terminate that which is not
i talk you know i talk you'd be
surprised i talk a lot when i'm on stage
i'm quiet when i'm at home
i'm very quiet when i'm at home i tend
to be a very quiet person
you gotta balance you can't just be
rattling all the time
it drives me crazy when people talk too
much
it drives me crazy when they just go on
and on and on and on because
see i pay attention
which you're not going anywhere with
this it drives me crazy
one of the strengths of preaching is
outline
because the outline gives the listener
something to follow
that has structure when you're all over
the place everything you're saying may
be true
but because your message has no focus it
becomes hard to follow
it's hard to follow somebody who doesn't
have focus
where are we going with this what is the
point of what are you talking about
get to the point what is this about and
for a while you'll listen
because you're trying to see if it has
structure and when you figure out
that they're just talking and it has no
relevance you go if you didn't get a
good job
you have to create a good job come on
yeah you have to create a job yeah
you have to carve out a niche in the
earth for yourself
and be creative you must realize that we
were created
by a creator who created us in his
likeness and in his image
and if our creator is a creator then i
have to be creative
somewhere down inside of every single
solitary person
in this room is creativity whether you
tap into it or not
we were not meant to follow a marching
band and follow it behind other people's
creativity
and not discover our own you
have creativity you have passion and you
have purpose
and giving people the freedom and the
wherewithal to to
build that i suddenly realized when i
sat down to write this book that
uh everything i ever experienced i had
to build from the ground up
i never inherited anything i mean my
father gave me a watch
and and i appreciate it and uh
you know my parents weren't so much into
what they left to you but they were
masterful at what they left in you
i came to deliver a message to every
person in this room who's had a struggle
who's had some pains who's had some
tests
who's got some creative ideas but you've
gone through some really tough stuff
let me tell you some of the stuff you've
been through don't pay it
any attention it is just a sign
that the baby is coming you're on the
verge of
birthing you're on the verge of birthing
you're on the verge of birthing you're
about to give birth
i want you to touch everybody you can
reach and tell them the baby is coming
the baby is coming
the baby is coming the baby is coming
the baby is coming
the baby is coming the baby is coming
the baby is coming
you don't want to leave me now the baby
is coming you don't want to walk out on
me now the baby is coming
i haven't had my best idea yet i haven't
had my most creative
moment yet i haven't produced my dream
yet i don't care whether you're 30 40
50 60 70. there's something down inside
of you that's still
kicking inside of you that wants to get
out and it wants to live
it wants to live the whole reason you're
here today
is because there's something in you that
needs to be fed
that needs to be stirred that needs to
be electrified
that needs to be illuminated there's
[Applause]
make some noise in this place
yes yes yes we are waiting on your water
to break
and for you to give birth to the
greatest idea
you have ever had make some noise
[Applause]
anybody who left you is going to miss it
they're going to miss it they're going
to miss the greatest part of you
the greatest part of your destiny the
greatest part of your creativity
it took everything you went through
yesterday to get you ready for what you
are about to do today
you are standing on the verge of a great
awakening
or you wouldn't be here if i'm talking
to you make some noise in this place
[Applause]
i can't hear you
i believe there are businesses in you
companies in you
concepts in you books to be written
paintings to be drawn concepts to be
birthed
ideas creative concepts there's
something
that you could do that you could think
in your life that would radically change
your life
somebody could take the hand you've been
dealt and
win with it same circumstances same
ideas
they would do it through what they
thought about your life
but we don't need somebody because we
got you
we got you you're the one
you are the one i want you to join hands
with somebody for just a minute
i'm telling you right now if you are
going to
birth your dream
your calling your passion
and the second half of your life you
can't draw back when life gets tough
you've got to stand up to it and push
get that person by the hand because
there's something inside of them
that is about to happen squeeze
their hand
[Applause]
and when i count to three i want every
man and every woman that's got a concept
that's got an idea
i want you to push with all of your
might
until dreams and concepts and ideas
start to birth out of you in the middle
of the night you're gonna need pens and
pads by your bed tonight
because you're gonna have to get up in
the middle of the night and start
writing down all the stuff
that's gonna start coming out of your
spirit when this day is ready
are you ready one
two three
[Applause]
god
[Applause]
the people who became the most
successful in our society are people who
broke the rules
you know there was no precedence for
24-hour news cycles until ted turner did
it
there's so many people who got out of
the box uh look at apple and the birth
of the whole notion of apple or nike i
talk about in the book of the birthing
of that corporation
how they did something with the tennis
shoe that had never been done before if
you only
base your decisions on empirical data
you can only repeat what somebody else
already did
if you follow your instincts and your
own god-given creativity
we could go where we have not been
before be strong
and very courageous be strong
and very courageous be strong
and be of good courage be strong
and possess the land because god knows
that for what you're going to do it is
not by our strength
you understand you understand she helped
me preach this thing this morning girl
it's inner strength so my fourth point
is you got to have inner strength for
this fight
it's not your outer strength it's not by
might
nor by power but by my spirit saith the
lord
so you got to have that inner that inner
that inner that god strength that
belly strength that devil defined
come hell of high water strength that
rolled me out in front of them and i'll
preach from a chair strength
that tenacity to take a licking and keep
on taking
that inner strength that well i can't do
as i would
i'm gonna do as i can but i'm not gonna
strong strong strong strong
since we're talking about business we're
talking about money you can't be tribal
and
be a global thinker at the same time the
reason money is called currency is that
it needs to be able to flow
and the issue is do you have a vision
that flows beyond people
who look like you dress like you and
vote like you and if you're gonna do
business you can't do segregated
business and do it well
if you've got a product that you believe
in or message that you believe in
or movie that you believe in or whatever
it is you want to reach the broadest
amount of people and most people think
travelly
all of their relationships their
contacts their associates are tribal
and you block the ability to succeed
when you block the ability to
communicate beyond your tribe
life demands that you pick up the pace
if you don't pick up the pace
you're gonna be left behind i'm amazed
at the people
that like the flexibility to pick up the
pace
they just get in a rut i scroll down
here
and i'm gonna stroll back i'm gonna
stroll
over here i'm gonna stroll over there
one of the most amazing things about the
disaster
at malaysia is that when it happened
everybody had to pick up the pace all
the news media had to pick up the pace
they were booking night flights and
flying over here and flying over there
somebody had to work overtime won't be
home for three days
typing in the middle of the night
research going on because when something
happens
everybody gotta pick up the page that's
why i
can't deal with people who cannot pick
up the pace
don't be strolling when i got a
up the 911
slap your name and say pick up the pace
something is about to happen pick up the
pace something's about to happen
pick up the pace something is about to
happen pick up the pace something is
about to happen
pick up the pace something is about to
happen pick up the pace something's
about to happen
i came to tell the young people pick up
the place pick up the page
pick up the pace something is about to
happen
the danger of low expectations
i would rather aim for the stars and not
hit them
than to not aim at all i would rather
go after it and not get it than not go
after it at
all i'd rather try and fail
than not try at all i don't want to live
with the idea
wonder what would have happened had i
done more with my life
i'm gonna go for it come on or
have water i'm going after
my destiny touch your neighbor and say
run
you gotta run after your destiny you
can't stroll
after your destiny you can't walk after
your destiny
you gotta run somebody holler wrong
you gotta run you gotta run
you gotta run you can't just wake up in
the morning let me see what's gonna
happen today
i don't know what i'm gonna do i don't
know what i'm gonna wear don't know what
i'm gonna cook
i don't know where i'm gonna go i just
woke up
oh you should stay in the bed give the
day to somebody
who's gonna run after their destiny give
the day to somebody who has a plan
who has a strategy because success is
never an accident
and if you don't want it get out of my
way because there are some people
who want to do something with their life
who will
run so many times you have a modicum of
talent in an area
maybe just enough talent to appreciate
people who are really called to that
area
it doesn't mean that you need to
necessarily go out and do that thing
you must understand that the purpose is
is the underlying
uh chemistry that makes you live your
life it may not be
you may not have a strong talent let me
give an example because i'm messing mine
up
let me give you an example i have talent
as a musician i can play the piano
not well enough to be maestro but i have
a modicum of talent in that area but
that was not my purpose
it but many many times we start working
in an area that we have talent but it's
not our purpose
i tell my kids this you may start out
doing something that is not
the thing you were created to do it may
only be the thing that
leads to the thing you were created to
do you understand what i'm saying
so so you can't don't stop
at where you are as if it were the
destination
when in fact in reality it may be the
transportation
that brings you into that thing you were
created fifth thing that i really
ascribe to
is balance work with play you can't do
all of either one and be successful and
to those who much has given much is
required
and if you work really hard you're
really diligent person make sure that
you do some play to balance your life
out
if you play real hard but you don't work
very much you're going to be fun but
you're going to be hungry
you know what i'm saying you got to
balance work with play
you have to balance that with your
children if you're always a
disciplinarian
your daddy gonna get you when you get
home i don't want to always be the
police in the house
yeah i want to be the fun guy sometimes
balancing work with play calls that's
not only for you to be holistic
but for people to get a better
perspective of who you are i get on my
instagram and i put crazy stuff
my kids die i just yesterday i put me
sweating in the gym
saying they said it's going to be fun
but it hadn't gotten fun yet
you know yeah you know to let people
know that everything is not serious
every day that's too much pressure
we've got way too much pressure on us to
be the people we were created to be
listen listen clearly i want to
pronounce
a benediction on every
grieving weeping depressed
lonely frustrated tired spirit
your period of mourning is over
touch your girlfriend your sister girl
your cousin or me mall
and tell her i cried my last tear
yesterday
yesterday i cried my last tear yesterday
i cried my last tear yesterday
i cried my last tear yesterday
i cried my last tear
yesterday you can send them flowers back
you can give that sympathy card back
you can stop looking at me all pitiful
you can stop seeing me as charity
i got my strength back i got my fight
back
i got my drive back i got my focus back
glory to god i'm forgetting those things
which are behind
and reaching to those things which are
before
i got some press down in me yeah
yeah shake your sister girl so i got
some press in me
that's how i got in here tonight i got
some press down in me
that's why i'm watching on television i
got some press down in me
i got some fighting me if you don't
believe i got some press in me
look back in my history and ask the folk
who
me ask the people who said i would never
make it i got some press in me
i made it without them i made it
make relationships count making your
relationships count because everything
is about relationships you're
first of all your relationship with god
you're that's a very important thing to
have
because as long as you know that there's
somebody in charge you don't have to
bear the brunt of the responsibility and
the weight of what's going on in your
life
you can talk to the boss okay number two
enjoy your relationship with yourself if
you don't like you it makes it hard for
me to like
you because people when you walk into
their atmosphere they draw you
into the cosmos of their own drama and
if they're full of drama without you
when you come in you become
caught up in the cyclone of their drama
enjoy your relationship with yourself
and then anybody else who comes in they
enter into a party you already started
you understand yeah yeah and then the
relationship with your kids the
relationship with your spouse the
relationship with your friends taking
time to enjoy the relationships
because there there is no fruit nature
teaches us
that there is no fruit without
relationships
you cannot be fruitful by yourself in
business
in home in life in church i don't care
what it is
you are no more than the relationships
you surround yourself with and
make sure that those are good ones you
call comfort in your book
a cage comfort in the cage we used to be
pioneers that's how the country was
settled
and and we start pioneering new things
we we stay where it's comfortable we
play where it's safe
we we don't really get out into the wild
of the possibilities we stay in the
confined
cage of of that that is uh tangible and
touchable
nine to five and that's it but we need
more creativity and we need to follow
our instincts now
without that you you may make some money
but you won't find fulfillment
always go to something
bigger than yourself
i'm wondering if you've been defeated
because you have been giving yourself
holy
to something that was too small to hold
you
[Applause]
have you trust yourself into a glass of
water
have you leaped off the diving board
into a cereal bowl person
are you not guilty of immersing yourself
into things that were too small to hold
your vision
[Applause]
oh my god this so good i'm gonna get the
cd myself
[Applause]
jesus sent him to throw himself
into something that was bigger than his
condition
and he had to go to get to it he had to
get out of his comfort zone
my problem is so many times you've
thrown
big ideas as small people
you've given big commitment to serial
bold people
and you're trying to get your sight back
from a source
that's too small to support
what you're willing to put in is your
investment bigger than the bank
you should see the way you're looking at
me is your is the reason you keep being
disappointed by people
is that you have wholly thrown yourself
into something
that was too small
jesus sends him to something that is
bigger than himself
so he can wash
his eye are you trying to take a bath
in a bowl david was a shepherd boy
out there trying to take care of the
sheep
and didn't have nothing to work with and
a lion came against him
and and he took a rag
and said this is the kind of stuff you
make to fight
back with when you don't have nothing to
fight with
have you ever gotten to a fight and you
didn't have nothing to fight with
but you took what you had and you said
such as i have
i'm not gonna let you take my stuff my
job my
opportunity my life my family's legacy
you after my family's legacy i'm not
gonna let you do it
and even though i don't have nothing
fancy to fight with
like a degree or like a million dollars
or like a bunch of friends but i'm gonna
roll up what i got
and i'm gonna throw it at you
[Applause]
you killed the lion
kill the bear
with this rag
this rag old dirty rag had thrown rocks
and everything that ever come against
you
if you live long enough a lot of stuff
will come against you
and you gotta you gotta
throw what you got at it
you can't throw what you wish you had
you can't throw what your neighbor had
you got to throw what you got at it
that's what separates the men from the
boys because you you got to throw what
you got at it if you don't
don't tell me that you want something if
you're not willing to throw
what you got at it number one you have
to own your own happiness
uh take it away from other people
demanding that they make you happy
your kids are not going to make you
happy your spouse is not going to make
you happy a big house is not going to
make you happy
own your own happiness and be
responsible for doing those things that
bring joy into your own heart
independently of life and people and
money and all of that stuff
it doesn't necessarily give you a
happiness you have to take
responsibility
of that peace and that joy that lives
inside of your heart and not inside of
your stuff
when i was in south africa on a safari i
was blessed to be on a safari after i
had taught for a group of black
billionaires
a seminar about faith and finances and
uh they detained me over and gave me the
the privilege of staying
uh out at j paul getty's place out there
in the middle of
the jungle somewhere and and to go on a
safari with my son
it was amazing so there i am in between
a zoologist
who is giving me all of this information
about all the animals their habitats are
mating practices how they live how they
operate
and sitting on the edge of the jeep with
a shotgun
to protect us we weren't hunting we're
just watching was a zulu
zulu says nothing at all the zoologist
explains all the animals and we visit
all the different places and see a lot
of the animals but we had not found the
elephant
he explained the elephant but he could
not find him finally there's a zulu
stood up and he put his finger in there
and pointed up he said the elephant is
over there
when he said it to me my head exploded
larry
it exploded because all of a sudden i
realized
i'm sitting between intellect and
instinct
intellect can describe it but only
instinct can find it
and from the premise of that ideology i
begin to go back through all of my life
and begin to see not only me but others
how if they position themselves between
intellect and instinct
and know when to yield to which one that
next big thing whether it's an elephant
an entrepreneurial pursuit or raising a
family
it is simply over there if you follow
your instincts
to be anxious is to have anxiety about
something that hadn't even happened yet
some of you are so worried about the
threat of trouble
you're not in trouble it's just that
trouble has threatened you
and the threat of what might happen what
could happen
it's wearing you now half of the things
that you thought were going to happen
never did happen but if you allow those
thoughts to dwell in your mind
it will succeed at robbing you of your
peace
robbing you of your joy robbing you of
your life just because you fought
yourself into a nervous breakdown
you thought yourself into depression you
thought yourself into defeatism
the mind is the battleground
the fight is in your mind so i want to
challenge you to waste
no more effort wrestling with other
people
i never wanted to be uh famous
i prayed to be effective wow
yeah i prayed to be affected and you
were
and you are you know paul i found out
that if you are effective effective will
bring fame
wow a famous not anything to be uh
famous not anything to aspire toward it
is something that you endure
yeah it's something that you endure fame
robs you of something that money cannot
buy
normalcy privacy uh
seclusion which is a healthy part of
mental health
to be able to have sabbaticals away from
crowds even jesus
escaped crowds at times to renew himself
so to all of you that are
that might be out there thinking you
know god make me famous
change that prayer today uh it's far
better to be effective
and i tell people all the time everybody
famous isn't great
and everybody graded and famous a lot of
people are afraid to build from the
ground up because we are
shown instant success yes overnight
wonders
yes somebody put something on youtube
and they exploded and now they're famous
and then we got people who are famous
for being famous
it used to be you were famous because
you were you did something now you're
just
famous you're just famous
and we got everybody who wants to walk
around and just be famous
but but the first thing god said wasn't
be
famous it was be fruitful right be
fruitful yes and if being fruitful makes
you famous and that's okay
as a young boy i was enthralled by
airplanes and the wonder of whether i
would ever embark on a flight that would
carry me to
new exciting adventures and a life of
limitless possibilities
i came to know i had the power within me
to soar
and that has made all the difference in
my life
flying for the first time is a lot like
creating your own business
launching a startup or establishing a
non-for-profit organization
both require a leap of faith and a
willingness
to take a journey of unexpected
variables
in other words both require a little bit
of crazy
and a whole lot of courage don't let
fear hold you back from doing what you
truly love commit to your vision and be
the ceo
of your future enjoy the journey not the
destination
a lot of us delay our happiness when i
get to this level when i get my degree
when i get the kids when i get married
i'm going to be happy
enjoy the journey enjoy the whole step
the whole process
every day that you get up to strive for
whatever it is you're after
you know i'm a goal-oriented guy yeah
but you don't celebrate when you get to
the finish line celebrate
all along the way celebrate all along
the way
now i've got a really special bonus clip
that i think you're gonna enjoy but
before that it's time for the question
of the day
i want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video
and write down in the comments below
when you're going to take
action on that takeaway this week when
you schedule in
what day what time and what place you're
going to take action
you have a 91 chance of actually
following through
compared to just 35 if you just got
motivated
but never created a plan and when you
share your plan and have accountability
you give yourself an even higher chance
of following through so in the comments
below
write down your single biggest takeaway
as well as your specific
plan of action because i want to
celebrate with you
let's talk about the eagles for a minute
because
the the mother eagle after
sitting on eggs protecting it with her
life
until they hatch and going out and
swimming and attacking prey
and bringing back food until they grow
then turns around the same beak that fed
them
and the same body that warms him takes
him out to cliffs
and throws him over the edge
it is not that she has turned against
her children
but she knows that they will never find
their wings
in safety
the eaglet learns to fly
by confronting its scary place
and it's not even trying to fly it's
falling
and flapping and thinking mama is crazy
i'm calling child protective services
i gotta get out of this but in the
process of falling and flapping and
falling
and flapping and falling and flapping
and
flapping and flapping and flapping
come on flapping and flapping
and flapping to change your life in the
next 30 days check the link right below
me and if you want one and a half hours
of will
smith motivation check out the link
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy it
continue to believe i'll see you there
you